about toxic access now this is a young
panel so I'm I'm hoping this topic still
works
no question what what is your definition
of a toxic X
someone that feels entitled to making
decisions for you
I feel like yeah yeah that's a toxic X
someone that feels entitled to to your
life to your lifestyle but that also
determines on whether you give them that
intact whether you give them that but do
you not like it when a guy has a bit of
like control that with me even though I
have a lot of control in my career and
in my life but I like to feel you know
petite and cute because I like when a
man
give it to me or I'd like to have like a
bit of um controlling that oh where are
you yeah I'm gonna say I want to know
what you care about me because you'll
say like the whole controlling thing
shows you that he cares as well I think
that's important in any relationship
yeah and this is confused you're nodding
and she says this you agree because but
she's saying the opposite of what you
said
I agree
like toxic oh like in an angry way yeah
in a controlling way as in
I would want you to show me that you
care I get that I like that I think she
means I can't lie I can't lie to show me
show me that you want me chase me you
know okay so show me that you want me
you don't want him to feel entitled to
making decisions yes but you want him to
chase you okay you want I'm just running
the stuff yes
that's a good thing there's a huge
difference between controlling and a bit
of dominance and I think that as a woman
I think being in a relationship like a
man that has a little bit of dominance I
think controlling and like constantly
checking where you are I feel like it's
a bit too much in my opinion anyway I
feel like there should be a level of
trust in a relationship
but no one I said when I said well like
where are you it's more of like oh are
you safe are you at home yeah okay yeah
so that's different yeah okay what's the
difference between controlling and
dominance I think a dominant man is
someone that can like make decisions
like say for example like
we're going on a date okay I'm picking
you up at eight I'm taking you somewhere
like that's kind of like dominance or
like did you get home safe or you know
checking up on you and making sure
you're good but like instead of being
like where are you what are you doing
who are you with show me who you're with
you you can't wear that outfit like that
is very tough so you want them to be
able to make the decisions but not the
decision of what to wear
[Laughter]
that means he trusts you though don't
you think there's a level of trust many
men yeah
manipulation not I don't think you guys
are really aren't answering the question
by what she said what is a toxic you
guys are just saying the guys being
controllers and manipulative I feel like
those are two different things yeah I
agree with that okay what do you think I
feel like a toxic relationship is when
two people are going at each other for
but in a way where you know that what
one person's saying is not good and what
another person saying not good but it's
like
in your head it's it's good to them but
in the end it's not good so it's like
you guys are fighting and batting like
okay what's like what's what's it's like
do you guys yeah you're clashing with
each other yeah you might love each
other to Pieces but if it doesn't work
and you have that Clash all the time
yeah then that's what makes it toxic so
extremely exciting yeah okay knowing
that it's not good but you're still
doing and you're still together
yeah so knowing it's not good but
staying together yeah yeah what about
what about rough patches and marriages
um I think rough patches and marriages I
mean because don't you argue all the
time during a rough patch in a marriage
you wouldn't think I agree but if you're
married to someone it's a lifelong
commitment and I think those are things
that you should be able to work through
by communication there's even like yeah
it's couples therapy even like if you
need to do it if you're willing to like
work through that then you can get
through it but yeah everyone argues yeah
see it's just it's very broad everything
you guys are saying I'm just trying to
lock you down under under one thing uh
go ahead I feel like it depends on what
the topic of conversation is and what
you guys are arguing about that then
depends if it's toxic or thing where I'm
correcting you and what you're doing is
wrong yeah let me say that again sorry
that all depends on what you guys are
arguing about for you for YouTube for
you to know whether it is toxic or thing
where you're just correcting a person
because
yeah
what wouldn't be an example of something
that's toxic and something that's not
I've got one of course that's a good one
deep breaths
like in other girls pictures on
Instagram following bad girls that is
toxic in itself I'm sorry don't you
think it's toxic to be constantly
looking who he's following and he's
liking it
sometimes it takes two to tango yeah but
by the end of the day yeah if you really
like one that person and you like the
person you're with like why do you need
to seek elsewhere why do you need to
have Temptation yeah but why are you
gonna get upset over an Instagram like
true because there's no actually stop or
tapping it because you clearly like what
you're saying if you like what you're
seeing things you don't think you're
looking for drama in a way
I'm trying to see if I can trust him
you're doing it for trust it's not just
me
shouldn't you go into relationships in
good faith no no no she's not everything
she said is by the reason why I'm saying
yes as you know we are gen Z the way
things were back then it's totally
different you guys didn't have social
media you guys didn't have phones but I
mean thank you guys I mean you've never
had before I had fun
exactly like you'll go to them you you
traps them right but now trapsing is
double tapping because it says a lot
about a man such discipline as well
that's really okay what about what about
when girls post selfies while in a
relationship yeah it's the same thing
that's the same thing yeah chapson is
double tapping and liking a girl's
picture that's showing that yes you're
you're attracted to them and when they
say would you say a toxic girl posts
selfies and and while she's in a
relationship if her intention sorry if
her intention is to get a reaction out
of that from a certain audience then yes
but what if his intention was just to
like the picture why would you just like
a and if anything let's have an open
conversation yeah you know what that's
yeah because I don't like a single guy's
picture or you know what I mean because
I would why would I give them the
satisfaction of seeing Mia me in their
notifications
I don't really think that liking a
girl's Instagram picture is that deep I
think obviously if they go ahead and DM
them and message them yeah but you can
appreciate someone's but you're
privilege you're praying you're putting
the goal but you can just go for your
couldn't you say the same thing about
women that post-suggestive Instagram
pictures while in a relationship that
they're they're looking for attention
even if it's just a selfie you know that
men are not you know how men are you
know well if they're in an open
relationships
complete different topics yeah it just
it really it really it's about body and
female empowerment in the day so we've
got obviously
it really just it really just sounds
like you want you want to do whatever
you want but he can't do whatever he
wants yeah
[Laughter]
with a man there should be a level of
trust there so you just you know that
already if he's like another Instagram
post it's never that deep because
of this because the trust is but you
shouldn't be in a relationship with
someone you don't trust the trash should
be there before you get into something
if you think about that happening
during a dating like when you're dating
like the dating base University
shouldn't you go into a relationship in
good faith like assuming but let's say
you're just dating you're not in a
relationship but you're about to get
into the relationship but then you you
know what I mean it's I kind of think
you're overthinking okay too much yeah I
think I mean if you guys are together
and it's something serious and then he
starts to go and follow loads
that's different I'm talking in the
dating phase well you're getting to know
each other and he's still lacking other
gods people you're both single so you
have the rights to do whatever you want
I think unless it becomes something
serious if you're single you're going to
chat to whoever and they're going to
chat to whoever and then if you decide
that it's something that is worth trying
for then you guys cut off your links or
you do whatever
because relationship with more based of
trust right yeah and then dating is more
for
I don't even know man
men are just I honestly think of them
[Music]
finish your men or what a man I just
some of you just need a pattern up some
yeah a lot of people you just don't who
do you think is more promiscuous men or
women hmm
another question for me I feel like
they're both promiscuous in different
ways I feel like females I feel like you
know what these days some of these some
of these females are using Instagram
like a dating app I don't know what is
going on they're posting that all these
random pictures that bro you don't have
to do all of that focus on yourself in
your career that are you trying to get
attention from I think a lot of God
there's attention seeking girls on
Instagram when it comes to pick one
who's who's more promiscuous promiscuous
yeah if we're talking about like
visually
you know I'm talking about who's who
sleeps around more oh oh who says okay
I'll miss about uh man question you say
man yeah yeah I'm gonna give you guys a
stat did you know one in three men under
30 are either virgins or haven't had sex
in the past year do you think one in
three women under 30 are either virgins
or haven't had sex in the past year
no
[Laughter]
I was gonna say I'm sorry is that true
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah it's crazy
though
do you guys um
do you guys like tall guys are you gonna
tall guys you like short Kings I mean as
long as that's older than me I'm sure as
it is
have you heard have you heard girls say
that they need a guy over six foot yeah
all the time
yeah
as long as you're taller than me do you
have an X over six foot
what percent of guys do you think are
over six foot
one percent
lucky guess 56 56 I'm gonna say 35 35 42
42. huh
um Harmony
I'm not drunk guys
um I would say 30 30 so it's only 15 of
guys wow and now think about it think
about it if uh how many people said they
have an ax over six foot you did you did
you did all sleeping with the same guys
not personally but women in general are
sleeping with the same guys because 80
of women want 20 of men
no that is mad so the reason like women
think men are trash and they think
they're sleeping around all the time is
because we go for such a small
percentage of of men and they are
sleeping around all the time but the
majority of men if you go to Tesco you
think they're getting a new play
okay so you'll see and you're saying it
comes to our choice in men right that
makes us think the rest are the same I
think that's the first statement
actually yeah I agree with that
yes that's a very interesting thing
because I feel like a lot of the time
like women when they're younger yeah
they go for like the bad boy or like
something and as you get older you kind
of realize that like certain traits that
you would like find attractive like
someone who's emotionally unavailable
they become unattractive as you get
older you're only 22 right I know what
have you been in a relationship but you
know I've seen so many like people get
into relationships and it's just and it
all flops something and it's like yeah
I'm scared
I'm actually terrified so um have you
guys had a toxic ax yep yes
um it wasn't an X but I guess yeah sort
of toxic yeah okay nope I've had people
who felt like they're obliged
by having a say in my life because they
like me
yes or no I need a yes
no me I would say yeah yeah okay um how
long were you involved with your toxic
ex a year and a half yeah did you love
him yes yes five years five years oh my
oh my goodness that is mad five years
yeah that is crazy did you love him last
time you know it's toxic five years you
didn't love him I don't know it was I
wasn't like in a relationship with him
but it was just a very toxic situation
so
okay so no you didn't love him yes or no
um I don't know maybe it was love to me
at the time at the time I don't think
his love like now when I look back on it
okay wow five years okay so I actually
have not been in a relationship like
properly where I can say oh you know
with boyfriend and girlfriend yeah but
I've been in a lot of situations where
I'm thinking again and I would say yeah
I must go and it's been quite toxic so
yeah you would yes yes and how long were
you with him
oh
I was with him for about
must be not five months not long five
months yeah I'm a busy woman I haven't
really got time did you did you love him
no no
okay so question question based on this
panel two out of four of you said you
loved your toxic acts and you were with
him for over a year would you say by
that statement young women love toxic
men
yes yes do you know what it is I think
when you're young you don't really know
your boundaries properly yet and a lot
of people put up with stuff that they
wouldn't usually put up with like I
always say now like men only treat you
bad if you let them if you let them yeah
if you let them treat you bad and you
don't if you don't respect your
boundaries then they're gonna walk all
over you and I think that's just bad
guys though I think that's just bad guys
like I think there's something about
young women like picking the Bad Boys
[Music]
they're gonna walk all over you if you
treat them well that's just yeah no 100
I'm the youngest in here and I will tell
you yeah it's because it's exciting it's
like almost like an adrenaline yeah
bounce off each other I knew it as many
of you know I was just banned on Tick
Tock and we are demonetized on a daily
basis on this platform if you want to
help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible